i think it starts from young i watch a
lot of cartoons from japan
you have your gacha man your captain
future and you have transformers
whenever look at this again every time i
look at my cabinets yeah when i say this
i will think about all my charcoal
memories like how i used to save up
money and run to the shop and purchase
it of course i'll take it out from the
box and i'll just play with it with my
friends hi my name is simon sim and i'm
49 years old and i'm a photographer
[Music]
i've been collecting for 20 years of
toys yeah my recent one will be kaiju's
kaiju sofa bee mainly is from japan and
but there's some from us and some from
uk i will go to japan every year once
and i'll try to buy from there i try to
make it for the toy show it's possible
if not i will just get it from the shops
over there
japanese yeah they are very creative in
in their own ways and then they find
that it's
their culture is really
something they're like taking out the
box so they
they create all these funny figures that
i can't see anywhere else for my
collections there's a various uh
makers and brands fabrics transformers
3a from hong kong cows choco kings
one of my favorite animation movie akira
i have the bike and also i have legos
with modulus kaiju of course here you
can see
from japan i do collect a few kaijus
before this but this one actually is
actually made me go
full mode his name is hirota
kasho and he made his own toys so these
are all handmade from his factory
and this is only by lottery so i'm quite
lucky that for my first lottery i got
this and it's been my favorites for so
long yeah this i would treasure for the
rest of my life yeah i think this is the
one
the rare one because
this is
number one out of 30 pieces gorilla
kinju
from hirota i was surprised actually i
got the number one the maker actually uh
selected the person to buy so i'm quite
lucky to to get one of these
japan is still one of the best
plastics and
i don't know why i think they have a
special mix in the plastic the the
combination is a bit
richer doesn't get sticky even in
singapore climate he's from u.s his
nvh
mutant vine hardcore from mandarake his
name is rich and yes he does wonderful
kaijus
his paint job is quite nice
and this is one of the rare
uh u.s artists that actually followed
but now he recently is his his lottery
is very hard because there's too many
people collectors are going for his
stuff now yeah
now recently uh for sofubi kao jius
there's a lot of collectors now like
from taiwan from thailand china hong
kong i'm competing with all these people
too these toys is quite limited like
maybe maybe 30 pieces i mean it's still
affordable i mean is it's about few
hundred dollars to stay okay the maker
will actually list how much is this uh
kaijo so from there if you think you can
afford it then you just join so to win a
lotteries i think you need to be a bit
lucky
i try to keep them inside this uh
my built-in cabinet this is a
custom-made i was clean maybe
once every half a year yeah i have
collected for 20 years and
i don't dare to
actually i didn't calculate how much i
spent because
i find that
putting all in prices will
have a different kind of direction for
me so i try not to do that
but
to estimate maybe
50 000 yeah if
for 20 years i think this should be
quite reasonable
on kaijus alone i think
i didn't even count it but about maybe
2200
think you need to put them on display
like i said if you keep it in the box
and not say it you need to show the
uniqueness of the shape the vibrance of
colors i love to display them and again
i can have a look at them anytime i want
to and share with friends and to my
families when you come to my place to
see my choice you have discovered like
bits and pieces every time you see
something new what makes me not to
follow like
collecting a certain themes because
i like variation so and also it's
different part of my life that's
changing so changing of a
thoughts perspective now everything is
so uh online and yeah so easy to get
yeah no it's different now it's not i
have the money i just need to click on
the button
and just buy it
so yeah in a way it lost a bit of that
nostalgic yeah i feel from last time
it was set
but i still have this the memories
that's how i started collecting
[Music]